just how much damage did you do to your
family's lungs with that batch of really
burnt caramel net at most weather
station can tell you though that's not
exactly what it was designed for the
aluminum monitoring stations tracked
temperature humidity barometric pressure
and carbon dioxide both inside and
outside you can access the data via the
web or by using iOS and Android devices
if your little candy-making adventure is
causing a hazardous air quality
situation in your kitchen net out mow
can let you know for example it might
display a warning that your co2 levels
are too high and suggest it's time to
open a window you can also track your
home's various levels over time to see
trends or use the system's outdoor
feature to determine whether to leave
your sweater at home or pack your
galoshes after all who are you going to
trust some TV station or your own sensor
network
you